[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ross tucker host of the ross tucker
football podcast works for cbs westwood
one you can uh
download the ross tucker football
podcast also follow him on twitter at
rosstuckernfl
and ross joins us on the program what's
your takeaway from last night's rams win
over seattle
oh geez um i got a bunch dan um both on
and off the field i guess i'm kind of
with you on the russell wilson thing
i mean
the first two times they had the ball
dan
they punted
on fourth and two and a half from the
rams 43
and then
they had the ball on the 31 yard line
and it was third and two
they run as it looked to me like a zone
read but russell wilson just handed it
to dj dallas so i guess he couldn't pull
it he gets tackled for no gain
then fourth down they run alex collins
right at aaron donald
get stoned i literally tweeted dan are
the seahawks aware
that russell wilson is their quarterback
like someone should probably tell them
and it's funny because i got a bunch of
replies from people saying that's why he
doesn't want to be there that's why he's
not going to be there if you just watch
those first two series and i know
russell watches the show or listen so
he's probably watching right now russell
you got to go somewhere else dude you're
like you can't be somewhere where the
first two drives of the game they punt
from the 43 and then run it on third and
fourth down when you're their
quarterback dude
what do you take away if you're uh the
rams
you know the one thing i guess i take
away obviously i think stafford is
certainly helping them from what he they
had last year in golf their defense
isn't playing as well you know they lost
brandon staley dan i guess it's kind of
what are you going to do but they lose
brandon staley to the chargers that was
a legit brain drain right there i mean
they had the best defense in football
certainly one of the two or three best
last year they're not nearly as good
this year now they did lose some guys
you know the browns picked off a couple
of their defensive backs
like johnson and hill so they did lose
some guys but they're also using jalen
ramsey a lot differently they're putting
him in the nickel a lot in the slot to
cover you know the slot receivers and
whatever they're doing it has not been
as effective and frankly they were
fortunate the way last night went even
at the end of the first half you know
russell throws a touchdown pass there's
a ticky tack holding penalty which by
the way dan is my other takeaway
from last night's game
two things number one clock
mismanagement yeah is an app is an
absolute epidemic in the nfl i i am
shocked
how often these guys screw up the clock
number one number two even just that
last drive
a very questionable
roughing the passer penalty on aaron
donald
followed by a questionable holding
penalty
on dwayne brown
that i don't think was a hold it was
ticky tack on a touchdown pass like
i know dan that if you were the
commissioner or if roger goodell called
you you would say to him
roger
why don't we if we're not sure
not throw the flag like what why are we
throwing flags on questionable calls
nobody wants that nobody asked for that
dan they're trying to protect us they're
trying to protect themselves
they don't want to be second guessed
that way hey when in doubt throw the
flag
it should be the opposite
it should be when in doubt don't throw
the flag all of us can live with
if they let him play a little bit more
okay aaron down he got to up to his neck
area but that was not much or donald
brown i mean dwayne brown okay i can't
but
let him play i mean nobody there's too
many flags it's very very annoying and
for some reason dan you know how many
ineligible man down field calls they've
had this year and i'm on all those
meetings before the season where they
tell you they never said that was a
point of emphasis they never said that
i've the eagles have been called for
four times already two of them
touchdowns
you're shot out of a cannon this morning
dude i get up at 4 30. i have way too
much iced tea because i don't like the
flavor of coffee so i i have like pure
leaf
iced tea for like three quarters of it
and i put in just a little bit of diet
snapple for the flavor just a little bit
because the whole diet snapple that's
like too strong for me so that's my
morning mix especially when i know i'm
going on with you
would you rather have aaron donald or
jaylen ramsey
aaron donald
yeah i think um
i think
a defensive tackle a dominant defensive
tackle
is the the most important position on a
defense
ramsey's very good but you can so often
just avoid him if you choose to
and even a defensive end
it's easier to chip those guys
quarterbacks are so good at stepping up
in the pocket when they run around the
edge you have a very impactful defensive
tackle you got problems i mean he had
like four quarterback hits last night
five pressures eight i mean he is
uh maybe one of the best defensive
players my rookie year was 2001
the best guy i ever played against best
defensive player was ray lewis i hope
people realize like aaron donald's that
kind of player like when they do 10
years from now belichick does that show
and they do the top 100 players ever
aaron donald is like a top 20 all-time
football player talking to ross tucker
host of the ross tucker football podcast
also does work for cbs and westwood one
as a color analyst we were thinking
about this
how many times how many teams have had
the two best defensive players at their
position in the league the rams
have that with jalen ramsey and aaron
donald right
yeah okay i was thinking about the
ravens ed reed
and
uh
lewis yeah
uh you know i don't know why this came
to my head
but
and this is kind of behind before my
time
dan but mean joe green and mel blount
well you also had jack lambert
yeah and uh jackie cam was good yeah
but i don't know if they were considered
the best linebackers
at their position but mel blunt at the
back end and you had me and joe green
certainly were trying to think who else
uh comes to mind did the cowboys have
anybody
uh
you had randy white or bob lilly but i
don't know if you had anybody in the
back end that was the best was there
anybody i'm trying was everybody in the
front seven when they had dion
in dallas well dion was in a variety of
places
uh so i'm trying to think that with
dallas did they have a charles haley was
charles but i don't think you know what
i i don't know if he was the best but he
was very good i'll give you another one
and uh paulie would probably suggest
this
richard den i don't know if he was the
best dn because of reggie white but he
was close and i think mike singletary
was the best middle backer
so when the 80 you know the mid-80s
bears had a shot about warren sapp
derrick brooks
john lynch
and rondae barber was out there too yeah
and simeon
hall of fame guys yeah and you had
simeon rice as well
who was a very good player to have it at
all three levels of the defense like
that too no wonder they won the super
bowl yeah uh james harrison troy
palamalu
i would say you know harrison was
defensive player of the year one time
yeah so yes
and then polamalu was probably the best
safety that year although i was always
more of an ed reed guy
uh those guys were just you know that's
another one of my takeaways from last
night dan
the seahawks are paying jamal adams
a lot of money to look that bad in
coverage
i mean but was he ever a coverage guy
though ross wasn't he a guy
he was a guy who came up to stop the run
no he's like a linebacker yeah and i
don't know why they're using him as a
deep middle-of-the-field you know
half-field safety but he did not look
good in that role i don't know they need
to blitz him he needs to be in the box
but he's not polamalu he's not ed reed
but they're paying them like that he's
not that kind of player
are you a baker mayfield fan
i am but i thought last sunday was the
worst he's ever played
probably by a decent amount and i think
the browns are going to have a real
decision on their hands
because would you pay him though
40 45 million dollars a year
no i would not
and it's weird because i think the guys
like him
i think he's a leader
i think he's a good quarterback i think
he's a top 20 quarterback but he's at
the bottom end of the top 20. he's not
even probably top 15
and i think the r the
the realistic portion of this
the reality is that i think there's a
lot of quarterbacks that can do what he
did they have the best o-line the nfl
they have the best run game
stefanski's a terrific coach
i think there are quarterbacks 20
through 27
in the nfl that could put up very good
numbers and win
with baker mayfield and you could pay
them a lot less
i just don't know why there's not middle
ground why is it the next quarterback
who comes up is going to make at least
40 million dollars
because if i'm the browns i don't want
to spend that kind of money
um you know can i do three years for 30
million or three years for 28 million
something like that why why is it
you're either cut
uh or you get the top top end money
you know what's funny about that dan
nobody else would give him that money
right like what who is the team
that's saying you know what we need to
do if he becomes a free agent we got to
get baker mayfield for 40 million here i
just don't think there's any other what
happens is
you're winning
and you have a guy you can win with and
teams get so afraid
of not having a winning quarterback a
top 20 quarterback
that i think they panic
and they pay them
because other teams aren't going to pay
baker 40 million they're going to say
we'll draft the next guy
or we'll take a retread project like a
sam darnold or you know a guy that
flames out with his first team
no one's gonna pay baker mayfield top
dollar so if i'm the browns i'm not
either
have a great weekend always great to
talk to you settle down a little bit all
right
i will calm down
uh hold on make love and need you one
ross we queued you up to talk about
buddy ryan's eagles defense and reggie
white jerome brown clyde simmons you
could any two defensive players there
you grew up like me on eagles yeah but
but reggie was the best at his position
the other guys weren't
i think uh i think you could have made
an argument for jerome brown a couple of
those years clyde simmons
mclovin how are you going to say clyde
simmons when he plays the same position
as reggie white
all right fine that there's no logic
there
hey this show needs more eagles love
i've been saying that ross you got to
help me here i'm on an island uh are you
all in on penn state versus iowa this
weekend
oh dude it's gonna be an awesome game um
i you know what's weird dan
for number three against number four
i feel like it's not getting that much
hype it's not
what why why is that the case like i
feel like because we're talking more
about oklahoma texas or the sec games
it's number three against number four
iowa doesn't get never happens iowa
doesn't get coverage because we buy into
iowa it seems like every year at some
point and then
they find the banana peel this is this
is the game that they would typically
lose i don't know man i watch them
against maryland they are very good but
look at you know hear what's crazy i
know i love your college football stuff
dan
there are
five teams at least in the big ten east
that are better than the second best
team in the big ten west like it's just
they gotta do something about it it's
just not equitable i mean i
if iowa beats penn state they're going
undefeated
did penn state recruit you
um you know what i got two handwritten
letters
from jerry sandusky ooh
believe it or not the first one was to
come to camp over the summer but i knew
i would run a bad 40 times so i didn't
do that the second one was uh you should
walk on but you know what's weird when
you're in high school
and they ask you to walk on i guess i
just figured i wasn't good enough so i
thought okay i'll go to princeton
harvard and then my rookie year with
washington
all the penn state guys were telling me
i would have started three years i would
have been like their best o-linemen that
i grew up an hour and a half from there
i had season tickets i was like
i can't hear you i can't hear you like
that that was my my wife still gets mad
because i still
would have loved she's like you went to
the best school in the country i'm like
i know but i could play to penn state
yeah
and and what your career could have been
you know it's funny you say that dan
no i i because in all sincerity
i probably would have been like a third
or fourth round pick i don't know if
that really makes much of a difference
but
your entry point matters right like
being an undrafted free agent
i you know the only spot i could make
was being the ninth and last guy on
marty schottenheimer's first team in o1
and then it's kind of always an uphill
climb
and your draft status always stays with
you whereas if you go to one of those
bigger schools and maybe you're a second
or third round pick and they're invested
in you it does make a difference there's
no question keep your head up okay
all right see you guys thank you that's
uh ross tucker one of our favorites